you
hi everyone is Gerry let's have a look
at a game from 1966 World Chess
Championship match round seven first
decisive game of this match on the white
end challenger Boris Spassky and he's
against the champ Tigran Petrosian
here's a nice photo of these two greats
both colleagues and adversaries you
could tell they had a great respect for
one another that's how I see it anyhow
when I look at the photo anyhow this
game is one that I first reviewed many
years ago much younger player and I
recall learning a very nice idea from
Petrosian and this idea is one that I
must have used several dozen times in my
own games over the years and even
variations of the idea looking at this
game on a more current note I realize it
fits not only into the educational
category but also entertaining it is
quite a unique game I think you'll agree
so let's dive in and see how it develops
Spassky opening with d4 we have a torii
attack Bishop g5 the term attack is a
bit misleading or can be a bit
misleading the king isn't going to come
under some heavy fire anytime soon or at
least that's not how it plays out in
this game it develops a bit more calm so
just getting the minor pieces out you'll
note that both sides keep their C pawns
free to advance this is commonplace when
you're working with a deep on based
opening they like to contribute one way
or the other in this instance we have
black as the aggressor light more
defensive with the C pawn these last two
moves by black are really the last three
an emphasis is on queenside deployment
keeping the option open with the King
not yet committing to castles King side
castle for white Bishop b7 and this
moment here move 9 Knight to e5 through
the first one to speak of this is now
the second white piece in Black's house
this is the more invasive of the two
Bishop on g5 is no bother this is no pin
but the knight on e5 a bit annoying
what does Petrosian do next I'll give
you two choices Queen c7 or Knight takes
Knight feel free to pause the video okay
here we go in the game Knight takes
Knight is played now an issue or two
that can arise if you play this
natural-looking Queen c7 Bishop b5 can
follow and the white miners start to
intersect in blacks house can be a bit
uncomfortable moreover you may never get
rid of the knight if Queen c7 is played
f4 can follow and then if you ever take
the knight that would mean the F file is
opened up for the white major pieces to
have some fun so the knight is knocked
out as soon as it arrives there white is
not given an opportunity to support it
with the F pawn and after Knight d7 one
more pop quiz what does Spassky play
here this is an extremely important
moment in the game and a turning point
in this game on this move 11 do you
capture the bishop or do you play Bishop
to f4 feel free to pause the video okay
here we go
in the game Bishop f4 is played and this
is an issue
Petrosian does very well to demonstrate
why this is the case Bishop takes Bishop
would be better even though you are
helping the Queen develop on the
recapture better because the e pawn can
now be conveniently defended with f4
as it plays out in this game the bishop
is on f4 some pressure is now being
thrown on e5 and the white pieces now
have to play a defensive role and their
position will soon be brought into
question petrosian's next move h6 this
is saying quite a bit this last move
moved 12 Petrosian is basically telling
Spassky with move 12
I'm not castling kingside I'm looking to
play g5 and start kicking around these
defenders of e5 unprepared to Castle
queenside and open lines towards your
king this is the direction we go we're
going to have an opposite sides castles
position on board
Spassky already anticipates this with
his next move
b4 says go ahead grab upon by taking
twice on b4 if you do you may never
Castle queenside Petrosian has no
interest in this he's not greedy g5 no
pawn grab bishop g3 h5 hunting the
bishop short on squares h4 is the threat
a square needs to be produced h4 on
board h2 is available now for the bishop
if you play h3 well one way or the other
a file will be cracked open towards the
king h4 in the game pawn takes pawn and
the bishop can't recapture it has a
responsibility
defendi 5 this is more important Bishop
f4 in the game black is up upon but
what's more important
the G file black has a path towards the
White King where is White's path towards
the black King in the game queenside
castle from here a four and now in my
introduction to this game this is the
moment move 17 and move 18 that I took
something away from what Petrosian did
what did Petrosian play on this move 17
and move 18 feel free to pause the video
what would you play here as black okay
here we go
move 17
see form now this is one of those moves
that makes this game interesting and
when I say game I'm not referring to
this specific game I'm talking about
just chess the moves see form is a move
you would see played by let me see if I
get this right I don't think this is
something I've ever shared in a video
before the move c4 as a movie would see
played by a beginner not played by
somebody more experienced like a little
bit more advanced and you would also see
c4 played by a chess great such as
Petrosian okay why do I think this well
a beginner they like moving pawn this is
just my own experience you like moving
upon so that it attacks a minor piece
okay the more advanced player isn't
going to play c4 because they understand
the deeper point a deeper point which is
to say that well the bishop will just
move you're not gonna get the bishop and
what have I just done I've given up a
wonderful square for the knight on d4
chess great somebody who sees a little
bit deeper understands that after c-4 in
the bishop move I can now play this next
move
what is this next move here we go
small move a6 what has just happened
here blacks last two moves c4 and then
a6 have done what they have shut down
the Queen side there will now be no way
white can create a path to the black
King if a five is played b5 the a B
and see files remain shut down if b5
there's a five ABC files shut down how
are you getting up the King Black has a
path where's yours
that's what is gained with these two
moves c4 and then a6 a complete shutdown
of the queenside why is this important
well this is going to give black all day
to shift his pieces towards the King
towards the Kings side towards the G
file meanwhile what is what does white
do what's White's constructive plan
there isn't one there's it's like white
is helpless - what black does next
if white excuse me if black does not
play a six in this position let's say
just throws a rook here notice after a
five in b5 trying to keep things shut
down it's not the same thing
if a six if this kind of structure is
available it's true the files are closed
but there's one key square that's
available and you could be sure the
white rook will make use of it in fact
Knight d4 and rook a five would
coordinate on b5 this is not something
black wants to tend to you do not want
to allocate pieces to the defensive
pawns
the way to avoid this is to make this
one little baby move this deep move a
six that's what I took away from
Petrosian with this game a small subtle
point but man can this really be applied
in your own games this idea to buy
yourself time opposite sides castling
positions okay in the game Spassky at
is king half of a half-open file the
rook D to g8 rock g1 rook g4 kind of
seems a little bit awkward to do this
your are opposite the bishop but black
is up upon and already anticipating some
possible exchange sacrifice a capture on
g4 would straighten out the black pawns
they would start to be pretty strong
from here Queen d2 battery on the G file
a5 is met with sure enough I mean this
was the idea with move 17 and 18 to meet
a5 with b5 locked down how do you get it
the king
Rick d1 bishop fe e 5 to attack
two defenders a moment away from a third
attacker
so Spassky plays Knight H - going for
the exchange pick up the rook
Petrosian says go ahead take it
Spassky does and in the end the pawns
have been straightened out what do we
have here we have an imbalance it is a
minor piece and two pawns versus a rook
but look at these pawns look at how
close they are to the King the side that
has that rook that extra rip white where
are the open files they don't exist how
valuable is the rook really in this
environment from here efore okay trying
to open up the D file create some pawn
exchanges black cannot take the pawn in
this position taking the pawn would be a
losing move because of Bishop takes
Knight and you can't recapture because
you get made it so no pawn takes pawn
black breaks this pin Queen to e3
if pawn takes pawn the bishop will be
there to recapture no big deal
Queen III Petrosian simply offers a dark
square Bishop exchange dark square
Bishop Saar off rook to d4 if something
other than rook to d4 let's say a
capture once more
we're just recapturing no problem keep
the diagonal open h3 right around the
corner in the game rook d4 is played and
now we have e5 rook is dropping back
f5 every black pawn will play in this
game and we are not done now if pawn
takes pawn the Queen can step over and
pick the pawn up pawn takes pawn on d5
and we don't recapture Petrosian does
not recapture on this point this is
another instructional moment I don't
know if when I first reviewed this game
that this moment it might have been
something I learned without really
realizing I learned something I'm not
sure if I'm explaining that as well as I
can but this idea to kind of hide behind
the white pawn capturing on this point
capturing on this move would not be a
good idea to be going into a self pin
this file is now closed so black is
going to work around that pawn f4
for Knight f6 Queen check King b8
now white would really like to play
Queen to e7 here offer a queen exchange
and maybe get the the D file open so the
the rook can do something but the timing
is not right playing E Queen to e7 in
this position would not be good
Spassky on move right now Queen e6 Queen
e6 is not good because in the end there
would be 94 that's a killer move see
what's happening here it's not about
Knight takes rook
it's about mate in two that's how
serious Knight to e4 would be in this
with this sequence so what is Spassky do
he eliminates this possibility Knight to
e4 now he's ready to jump into e6
Petrosian sniffs this one out says no
way Bishop c8 go away go back home Queen
B 1 and now G 3 these pawns continue to
march this rook is dead every white
piece is dead what are they doing
nothing from here rook to e1 h3
King needs a square the h-file is gonna
be opened up it's preparing to run but
he won't run too far bishop f1 rook AJ
on takes Bishop takes bishops are off
and from here we're not done with these
pawn moves
efore what do you do if you take with
the rook you lose the Queen Queen here
Queen to d1 Queen back home if you take
like this there's f3 in the game queen
d1 Knight g4 it's just a fantastic game
just leaving the knight out for what
exactly well for one he's ready to jump
into e3 that's a killer check you know
even if white tries to give up the
exchange that'd be too much black would
have 2 passers and still a winning
attack along the h-file in the game the
knight is captured and now we continue
to push f3 talk about some killer pawns
controlling all four squares mate ah h1
next Spassky plays rook g2 well what
else is there it seems like a really
weird move to make but how else are you
defending against the main threat on
each one if you play King g1 in this
position there's Queen h6 you're not
stopping checkmate
so in the game rook g2 pawn takes rook
and well Spassky simply resigns at this
stage move 43 is the last move so if it
did continue King takes pawn we can have
a check and then Queen h6 check
checkmate is the threat there's no no
good defense here it's just a winning
attack made possible in large part by
these earlier decisions on moveset this
reached what move 43 but going back to
move 17 and 18 c4 in a6 this is what
enabled this type of attack towards the
white king this is what bought so much
time for Petrosian to pursue an attack
against the white king anyhow as usual
feel free to leave any feedback to this
video in the comment section below I
hope you enjoyed it and maybe even took
a thing or two away that's all for now
take care bye
you